plus loin comme chaque soir à 20h40
heures de Paris retour sur deux infos
qui font l'actualité de cette journée en
compagnie ce soir de notre chroniqueur
internationale gauthierrybinsky bonsoir
Gauthier ravi de vous retrouver de ziade
l'imam directeur du mensuel Afrique
Magazine bonsoir à vous également Zia
dont va plus loin tout d'abord ce soir
sur les résultats toujours pas
définitifs des meeters aux États-Unis
alors où l'on se parle le camp
républicain aurait 204 sièges à la
Chambre des Représentants contre 176
pour les démocrates c'est beaucoup plus
serré au Sénat 48 sièges côté
républicains contre 46 pour les
démocrates on va tout d'abord écouter
tour à tour le démocrate John Fetterman
victorieux en Pennsylvanie et le
républicain Rhône De Santis qui l'a
emporté haut la main en Floride
je ne croyais pas que nous réussirions à
faire passer ce compte est rouge au bleu
démocrate mais nous avons fait ce que
nous avions à faire et nous avons
argumenté à chaque coin de rue oui
nous avons embrassé la liberté nous
avons maintenu la loi et l'ordre
protéger les droits des parents et
respecter nos contribuables
aujourd'hui après 4 ans au pouvoir le
peuple a rendu son verdict la liberté
reste en Floride
malgré ses résultats pas de vagues
républicaines malgré j'ai envie de dire
tout l'argent qui a été dépensé alors
malgré tout l'argent qui a été dépensé
malgré le bilan a absolument
apocalyptique que la droite américaine
faisait du début des années Biden les
deux premières années inflation crise
économique
difficulté etc donc
a priori il y avait absolument un
territoire favorable et donc le fait
qu'ils n'ont pas gagné
les démocrates n'ont pas gagné non plus
vague probablement créer quelque chose
au sein du parti républicain une
réflexion sur pourquoi on n'a pas écrasé
ces gens-là on aurait dû c'était notre
année sur les sondages un petit détail
j'ai appris aujourd'hui je crois
d'ailleurs c'est sur un de vos un de vos
correspondants ou un de vos
collaborateurs qui a expliqué comment
fonctionne les sondages aux États-Unis
ça marche avec le téléphone avec fil à
la maison autant dire qu'on s'adresse à
la partie la plus âgée ou la plus
agréable du pays et donc forcément ça
peut se représenter mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est ça c'est vraiment je
pense qu'au niveau du parti républicain
il va y avoir une vraie réflexion sur
pourquoi on n'a pas gagné pourquoi on va
pas prendre le Sénat le Sénat ça va
prendre jouer le 6 décembre en Géorgie
dans un deuxième tour
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une remise en
cause du Trump est-ce qu'il va y avoir
un renouveau des républicains dit
modérés est-ce que est-ce que le centre
va retrouver de l'intérêt parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il y a beaucoup de
batailles qui se sont joués au centre
est-ce que le fait qu'on est présenté
des os des vrais des vrais allumés ce
que ça peut jouer en notre défaveur
est-ce que le fait qu'on se soit mêlé
d'un débat sur l'avortement dont on
pensait qu'il passerait à la trappe
finalement ça a mobilisé les j'allais
dire les bases démocrates et en
particulier les femmes et les jeunes
donc ce qu'ils appellent en anglais le
sol churching il va y avoir du saultier
parce que c'est pas une c'est pas une
c'est pas une victoire mais c'est ça
aurait dû l'être pour eux c'est beaucoup
plus serré au Sénat Gauthier Ziad
l’évoquer à l'instant et effectivement
la Géorgie sera un état clé pour
exactement le même acteur et alors
justement avec des personnages qu'on
commence à connaître là aussi c'est très
surprenant parce que vous avez un
gouverneur de Géorgie qui est Bryan Kemp
qui est un homme dont je me souviens
qu'il le les spots de campagne étaient
en permanence il était en permanence à
portée ou en portant une arme
et donc il faisait même des cartons
pendant ce spot pour expliquer qu'il
était particulièrement fier de porter
une arme et qu'en plus c'était un bon
tireur voilà le profil de Kemp c'est
quelqu'un qui normalement aurait dû être
dans la botte ou dans la main de Trump
or patatra Trump craignant justement que
ce bonhomme prenne un peu trop
d'importance lui adjoint enfin lui
adjoint non il lui met dans les pattes
un autre candidat et là c'est le
problème parce que c'est quand même
c'est quand qui malgré tout est en tête
alors ce qui va se passer après sur les
sur le si le 6 décembre là c'est autre
chose parce que ça va être un conflit on
va dire un peu plus habituel mais d'une
façon générale est-ce que comme
disaitiade est-ce qu'on n'est pas à la à
l'orée d'une réflexion enfin des
républicains dont certains disent quand
même qu'ils ont perdu leur honneur en
étant trumpiste en étant par exemple
tout simplement le fait que le rigorisme
moral qui était celui des républicains
souvent
trouver dès le Texas c'est vraiment de
deux discussions intéressantes en
Floride ça a joué beaucoup sur la proche
de deux senti sur le covid le fait qu'on
a jamais fermé l'iPhone 8 que la Floride
était toujours en état de marche même si
ça a tué une génération de gens fragiles
bon ça tout le monde a oublié et donc il
a cette idée que il attire beaucoup
toutes les boîtes de la tech qui étaient
en Californie de qui sont en train de
bouger vers la Floride il y a eu aussi
les Hispaniques qui sont en train de
changer parce que les Hispaniques sont
très motivés par les questions
religieuses donc quelqu'un qui leur
parle de de Dieu de la région ça
fonctionne et au Texas on est vraiment
sur un modèle
ultra conservateur américain moi j'ai
été absolument stupéfait de voir que
dans la ville où il y a eu la tuerie des
enfants
c'est un républicain porteur d'armes
pure et dur qui a gagné contre un
démocrate qui voulait changer donc faut
pas l'Amérique n'a pas changé elle est
toujours dans les mêmes contra les mêmes
conflits mais il y a quand même la
question Trump qui est posée et du côté
des démocrates on a une génération qui
arrive parce que le problème des
démocrates c'était leur vieux président
qui fait des gaffes qui se perd par
est-il dans les jardins de la maison
blanche qui confond l'Irak et l'Ukraine
donc on commençait un peu à flipper et
donc apparaît dans ces élections en
particulier au niveau local ce que les
démocrates avaient un peu abandonné
depuis quelques années des visages des
gens qui peuvent incarner le futur du
parti on parle en particulier de cette
fameuse gouverneur du Michigan Gretchen
witner on parle du Obama plus et j'ai
entendu l'expression aujourd'hui du
homapa plus plus qui est le gouverneur
de qui s'appelle Westmore qui est et
donc tous ces gens donnent de l'espoir
parce qu'on se dit bon si binden n'y va
pas on a des options de gagner dans deux
ans et donc la base du parti est assez
mobilisée encore une fois ce que je vous
disais c'est qu'on découvre que le
centre a de nouveau de l'importance que
dans les batailles qui se jouent à 55
ans c'est pas les plus utiliser qui vont
faire la différence et cette espèce
d'électorat mouvant plutôt jeune assez
féminin les banlieues ont soutenu les
démocrates voilà donc c'est là que ça va
se jouer et donc Trump a un problème
parce que c'est la stratégie totalement
différente mais comme il a aucune limite
comme il a la justice aux fesses comme
il veut pas mourir à tout point de vue
politiquement etc il peut faire
n'importe quoi c'est absolument possible
que dans les deux ans ou dans l'année
qui viennent quelle que soit le résultat
de ces élections il soit tout aussi
difficile à manipuler y compris pour les
républicains qui voudraient le oui
changer pour rebondir sur la
mobilisation de l'électorat démocrate
visiblement la question de l'avortement
du droit l'IVG a beaucoup mobilisé
durant la campagne on disait que les
questions économiques notamment
l'inflation écraser tout et visiblement
cette question l'avortement était quand
même cruciale alors oui c'est un vieux
débat entre Américanistes on dit souvent
les États-Unis votent sur des issues ce
que l'on dit en anglais c'est à dire des
questions au fond de société et puis
d'autres disent mais non pas du tout au
fond c'est sous tendu par des
préoccupations très j'allais dire
habituelles classiques qui sont celles
du pouvoir d'achat du coup de la vie de
l'éducation etc et là moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est un c'est un mix
des deux parce que la question de
l'inflation le fait que le carburant est
sauté des plafonds jamais connu ça
existe bien mais j'ai l'impression que
cette question fondamentale de
l'avortement est sorti aussi un peu
comme un marqueur idéologique c'est à
dire que les gens ont dit oui même si je
ne suis pas concerné même si voilà je
suis un homme de
70 ans je m'intéresse à ça parce que
c'est le marque la contestation du droit
l'avortement et le marqueur de la droite
et de l'extrême droite et donc par effet
de ricochet si vous voulez ce thème a
pris de l'important je ne dis pas qu'il
en a pas d'habitude je dis simplement
qu'il a pris une importance parce que il
désigne il est très polarisant et de ce
fait là on peut comprendre qu'il le soit
il désigne celui qui finalement n'est
pas que celui qui veut imposer sa loi
parce que tout simplement moi je pense
qu'il y a des gens qui ont voté
démocrates parce qu'ils estimaient
qu'effectivement la défense de ce droit
c'est un droit n'oublions jamais une
lapalissade un pays qui autorise
l'avortement c'est un pays qui ne
demande pas à chaque femme d'avorter
alors que quand on interdit c'était
coercitif pour tout le monde mais je
pense qu'il y a eu ça qui a eu des gens
même et pris de ce fameux esprit de
liberté américain qui sont dit je ne
peux pas laisser faire ça parce que de
l'autre côté c'est la marque c'est le
symbole c'est la figure de proue presque
d'un obscurantisme qui est celui de
l'extraitante américaine alors autre
thème on va plus loin ce soir c'est très
vive tension entre la France et l'Italie
autour du sort du navire humanitaire
Ocean Viking avec 234 migrants à bord ce
cours je vous le rappelle en mer
Méditerranée alors qu'elle fuyait la
Libye et tentait de rejoindre le
continent européen déjà 18 jours
d'errance pour ce bateau qui demandent
désormais un port sur en France faute
d'une solution de débarquement en Italie
pari dénonce je cite le comportement
inacceptable de Rome pendant ce temps à
bord la situation est catastrophique
selon SOS Méditerranée des gens menacent
même de se jeter par-dessus bord on va
tout d'abord écouter le porte-parole du
gouvernement français Olivier vérante
c'était ce matin
ce bateau est actuellement dans les
autres territoriales italienne il y a
des règles européennes extrêmement
claires et qui ont été d'ailleurs
acceptés par les Italiens qui sont de
fait le premier bénéficiaire d'un
mécanisme de solidarité financier
européen ce bateau il a vocation à être
accueilli en Italie l'attitude actuelle
du gouvernement italien et notamment les
déclarations et le refus de laisser
accoster ce bateau
contrario de toutes les règles
européennes qui ont été acceptées par
l'ensemble des pays de l'Union est
inacceptable donc nous souhaitons à
l'heure où le bateau est encore dans les
autres territorial italienne que
l'Italie joue son rôle et respecte les
engagements européens alors le Sean
Viking serait en ce moment entre la
Sardaigne et la Sicile Ziad que dit la
loi maritime internationale et ce qui a
effectivement un manque de respect des
engagements du côté italien en fait il y
a plusieurs j'allais dire il y a
plusieurs il y a une loi il y a de la
jurisprudence la loi c'est que le port
le plus proche c'est le port où on
débarque après il se trouve que en
Italie et systématiquement le port le
plus proche pour ceux qui viennent de
Libye ou l'Espagne pour ceux qui
viennent du Maroc mais on aurait pu
parler et se rappeler de la situation de
la Grèce quand il y a eu quand il y a eu
les grandes vagues migratoires venant du
Moyen-Orient traversant à pied bon c'est
un peu toujours la même histoire et donc
en fait chacun de ces bateaux parce que
au moment où on parle de chien de viking
qui est bloqué il y a quatre autres
bateaux qui ont accosté en Italie
absolument normalement donc on voit que
derrière ces drames humains parce que
c'est un drame humain pour ceux qui sont
dans le bateau c'est à chaque fois une
négociation de marchand de tapis
absolument
c'est vraiment pas à l'honneur de tous
ces pays riches européens pour
équilibrer cette espèce de loi qui fait
qu'il y a certains pays qui sont en
ligne de front et d'autres pays qui sont
en ligne arrière et les pays qui sont
alignés arrière en particulier la France
et l'Allemagne ont pris des engagements
qu'il ne respecte pas parce qu'ils
avaient promis d'en prendre je sais plus
les chiffres 3000 6000 8000 et en fait
on est à 76 27 42 donc on est vraiment
dans
dans le dans le déni et donc face à
quelque chose dont on sait que c'est un
phénomène de tendance lourde qui est
cette émigration du désespoir parce
qu'il y a aussi des émigrations il y a
des émigrations tout à fait normal le
et c'est instrumentalisé à chaque fois
par exemple en France la droite et
l'extrême droite on profite pour
flinguer le projet d'armanin qui
consiste en fait à créer une filière
d'émigrations à l'anglosaxonnes à
l'américaine à l'anglaise à
l'australienne les métiers en tension et
que ça donc ça devient des débats
intérieurs c'est un débat européen qui
n'a jamais été éclairci entre comment
comment répartir le poids de cette
migration du désespoir parmi les pays de
toute la zone de l'Union et c'est en
même temps une sacrée dose de cynisme
par rapport à ces gens dont on voit les
images qui sont là dans ce bateau depuis
19 nuits qui sont otages en fait de tous
les non-dits de l'Union européenne et
des pays européens sur la question
Gauthier hier la nouvelle présidente du
Conseil italien Giorgia Meloni donc
d'extrême droite a présenté comme acquis
l'accueil de ce bateau par la France or
la France n'a jamais confirmé qu'elle
allait accueillir ce bateau à quoi
est-ce qu'elle joue enfin c'est un peu
poker pour mettre la pression oui si la
manœuvre est avérée c'est assez simple
c'est de dire
ces gens ces pays qui font partie de
l'Europe à propos de laquelle nous
italiens donc nous gouvernement italien
sommes particulièrement
disons suspicieux il ne joue pas le jeu
c'est eux qui ne jouent pas le jeu c'est
la France qui prétend qui dit ou
mauvaise accueillir puis au dernier
moment de manière totalement versatile
je continue la réflexion que je prête à
George Meloni de manière totalement
versatile comme les autres pays
européens il se débine au moment où et
bien moi dit-elle moi jameloni je ne
vais pas laisser faire ça vous voyez le
le subterfuge le stratagème est assez
simple mais il répond et là je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ce que disait il
aussi à des manquements qui sont ceux de
la France pour ne citer qu'elles en ce
moment-là et si vous voulez à travers je
rejoins aussi ce que ce que tu disais à
travers le cet espèce de banalisation de
l'affrontement même de l'affrontement
verbale s'entend de la fontement entre
l'Italie la France entre l'Europe qui
n'a pas fait son boulot etc cette
banalisation tant à déshumaniser
totalement ces gens
on a l'impression si vous voulez
qu'effectivement c'est une quantité donc
il faudrait se décharger et personne ne
parle de ça personne ne parle de ces
gens vous avez bien vu même Olivier
Véran dit bon alors c'est une affaire de
territoriale je veux bien sûr que c'est
ça aussi mais on est en train et c'est
là que quelqu'un comme mélodie peut
gagner la partie si on continue à
traiter la chose dont seulement en ces
termes-là mais à l'appeler à la dénommée
de cette de ces termes-là c'est quelque
chose de perdu et d'absolument honteux
et forcément si vous voulez si vous en
arrivez à cette à cette réification de
l'humain après vous ne soyez pas étonnés
que lorsqu'il s'agit de discuter vous
soyez encore dans cette optique là et
qui ne tient pas compte de ces gens
alors rapidement pour conclure le bateau
pourrait arriver au large de la Corse
des deux mains Gilles Siméoni le
président de l'exécutif Corse a dit que
l'accord c'était prête à les accueillir
c'est d'ailleurs pas la première fois
Ziad que la Corse
se propose est-ce que c'est purement
généreux de sa part ou c'est aussi une
volonté de
pied de nez à Paris je pense qu'il y a
un peu de tout et puis
[Musique]
mais ça reste quand même une
responsabilité et que sur le plan
institutionnel ça reste une
responsabilité de l'État central donc la
Corse peut dire marseille peut dire
chacun
les accueillir sa carte comme ça encore
une fois ce que ce que tu disais c'est
l'instrumentalisation banalise la
réalité de la tragédie humaine et
surtout
fait en sorte que le débat européen de
fond sur l'immigration n'est pas n'est
pas pris en main d'abord parce que c'est
pas c'est pas un débat c'est pas une
compétence de l'Union c'est une
compétence des États membres donc chacun
il va de son côté vous savez c'est comme
l'histoire de c'est comme l'histoire de
des migrants qui passent de France à
l'Angleterre bon bah ça fait des années
qu'on traîne un traité pratiquement
inapplicable mais bon voilà on laisse
ces choses s'installer
merci beaucoup Ziad merci aussi à vous
Gauthier pour vos éclairages c'est la
fin on va plus loin rester avec nous sur
France 24 Paris direct se poursuit dans
quelques minutes
[Musique]